[Música]
importantes temas destacados en el mundo
de la economía de la jornada de hoy ya
está con nosotros Daniela Blandón
Daniela Buenas noches bienvenida
comenzamos hablando de esa reducción de
la jornada laboral en Chile Más allá de
las horas en qué consiste Daniela Hola
Santiago Buenas noches pues en el
escritorio de Gabriel boriche ya está
este proyecto de ley muy reñido en el
parlamento para reducir gradualmente la
semana laboral como ya lo decíamos a 40
horas desde 45 horas máximas se espera
su promulgación para el primero de mayo
que es el día del trabajo el gobierno
espera entonces beneficiar a unos 4
millones de trabajadores con esta
reducción que va a ser gradual baja una
hora el primer año otras dos horas el
tercer año y cuando llegue al quinto ya
debe estar en 40 Aunque depende del
empleador también si quiere anticiparse
y no esperar esta gradualidad sino
hacerlo de una vez la norma también
incluyó la posibilidad de implementar la
semana laboral de cuatro días por cada
tres días de descanso y las llamadas
bandas horarias es decir hora especiales
con hasta dos horas de diferencia de los
horarios normales para quienes tengan
hijos menores de 12 años esto entre
muchos otros regímenes especiales que
dependen del trabajo de la persona chile
puede servir de ejemplo y de experimento
digámoslo así para otros países de
América Latina pasemos ahora a hablar de
Estados Unidos porque allí piden bajar
ese sentimiento de pesimismo en las
proyecciones económicas qué dicen por
ejemplo en América Latina pues Santiago
el fondo monetario internacional y el
Banco Mundial presentaron su más
reciente informe de perspectivas que
dice que la economía podría crecer
apenas 2,8% este año pero la secretaría
del tesoro de Estados Unidos sin
referirse directamente a esos
prestamistas globales si hizo un llamado
general a mejorar la actitud frente a lo
que está pasando
no exageraría con el negativismo sobre
la economía global
los países de bajos ingresos continúan
mostrando un crecimiento resistente
algunos de ellos están iniciando de la
mejora en sus términos de intercambio y
han acumulado amortiguadores y tomado
fuertes medidas de política
macroeconómica por lo tanto creo que
deberíamos ser más positivos por
supuesto existen riesgos y muchos de
ellos se relacionan con la guerra de
Rusia contra Ucrania
Daniela nacional vale la pena preguntar
qué dicen de todo esto en América Latina
América Latina es un caso muy particular
porque mire el año pasado la región
creció más que todo el mundo como lo
vemos en este gráfico concretamente 4%
frente a un 3,4% global pero para los
próximos dos años se espera que el
crecimiento esté por debajo de lo que va
a hacer el crecimiento de todo el
planeta Y si hablamos de casos concretos
este informe refleja desempeños más
débiles en algunas economías grandes
Como por ejemplo Japón Alemania India o
Brasil en cambio Estados Unidos Sí se ve
más sólido es difícil ser positivo con
unas tasas de inflación tan altas en la
mayoría de los países y de interés por
supuesto hablemos ahora del gobierno
cubano que ahora permite los depósitos
en dólares Santiago en 2021 se prohibió
la tenencia de depósitos en la divisa
estadounidense y ahora El Ejecutivo
público una ley que revierte esa medida
Pero entre la población la opinión se
divide como nos lo explica Marta Moya
revertir medidas para paliar la crisis
económica en la noche del lunes el
diario oficial de Cuba publicó una
resolución por la que se da luz verde a
los depósitos en dólares estadounidenses
en el sistema bancario local dando
marcha atrás a su propia prohibición
promulgada en 2021 cuando el gobierno
argumentó que el bloqueo de Estados
Unidos imposibilitaba que Cuba sacara
dinero al exterior en dólares la
bancarización del dólar es una medida
motivada por actuales condiciones del
país que beneficiará la actividad
económica nacional y a la población a
pesar de la vigencia de las medidas de
Estados Unidos que obstaculizan los
flujos financieros de Cuba e impiden
depósitos en el exterior de dólares en
efectivo el Banco Central confirmó que
dada la situación económica de La Isla
la medida Era la más aconsejable todo
ello mientras la nación caribeña
recupera paulatinamente el turismo tras
los impactos de la pandemia de covid-19
entre la población las opiniones están
divididas en torno a esta medida eso es
algo positivo que realmente se debería
haber hecho hace mucho tiempo no
lo que ayuda a la economía realmente en
todo en todo sentido yo apuesto por el
cup es nuestra moneda es la que hay que
fortalecer Y esa es la que nos va a
nosotros llevar a salir de todos los
problemas que tenemos hoy aún cuando
tengamos que usar todas las otras
monedas internacionalmente para hacer
transacciones para comprar y todo eso
pero yo la he puesto en mi Cuba al cvp
una inflación del 39% en 2022 en la isla
exacerbó la escasez de Divisas
medicamentos alimentos y combustibles
mientras la limitación de dólares creó
un mercado ilegal de facto que ahora se
podría regularizar para el cierre
indicadores Cómo se comportaron las
principales bolsas alrededor del mundo
a la espera de que esta semana se
conozcan datos de inflación y de precios
al productor que se van a publicar el
miércoles y el jueves respectivamente
Europa cerró positivo con el principal
índice francés en nuevo récord histórico
y con Londres en un mes en máximos de un
mes impulsado por las acciones
petroleras y mineras y en América Latina
la Euforia se tomó la bolsa de Sao Paulo
que subió más del 4%, esto después de
que fueran revelados los más recientes
datos de inflación Santiago
4,65% interanual en marzo esto es uno de
los más bajos de la región si no es el
más bajo es un indicador bastante
positivo para esa economía tan grande
Muchas gracias Daniela por esta
actualización del mundo de la economía a
continuación en directo a América ya
viene el debate
[Música]